what do you think of Dave Chappelle I I
think he's brilliant yeah of course he's
brilliant I think Dave has become he's
transcended from comedian to dang your
Bigfoot there's sightings of them and
then people just get excited being in
his presence and that's what I always
say about these these comedians like
someone like Kevin Hart Dave Chappelle
you're talking about the what we
consider the top of the food chain right
now whether you see their special and
you're like ah I've seen better whatever
you don't understand why they are where
they are at until you're in their
presence and then when you're in their
pres like I get it but what happens at
the Times where joke offensive joke
derogatory joke but it was a joke people
laugh and let it go now if you say
something people trying to get you
cancelled they're trying to get your
sponsorship taken away Shaq is not like
that what you mean it's not like that
it's not I'm telling you cancel culture
they are going after dve Chappelle every
time he does those jokes but it doesn't
matter he's still selling out he's still
getting more specials I know that but
I'm but I'm asking